obviously the Davidson figueretta weight
cut always Bears watching but I think he
has sort of mastered that at this stage
of his career and then for Brandon
Moreno wholesale changes at least as far
as his head coach right it was Raul
arvizu team entrom then it was James
Krauss and now it looks like it's going
to be the general safe side I don't
think he can do much better than safe in
terms of a coach on fight night but I do
think it's an interesting storyline
leading into this historic fourth
meeting no one's ever fought four times
I'm a huge fan of Moreno so I hope he
gets out there and gets it done he's
just one of my most favorite people on
the roster can't wait for it I don't
know what to expect because I've never
had that much octagon experience with
one guy like you know a speed you know
you know his reach you know his power
you know everything about the guy
hopefully I've finished I kind of don't
want to see another 25 minute War I like
to just I like for one of them to just
put a snap on it and get a finish
foreign